good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday happy
hump day and claudia you are in studio
ugh i miss the toasty vibes how's it
going over there it's good yes i came
into studio today because today's
episode if you're listening as a podcast
right at the end we're doing a really
hard-hitting interview with brian kelly
who's been in the news a lot i don't
know if you guys know brian and his
company are suing american airlines
american airlines is suing them it's
like all this drama and i kind of just
wanted to break it down because it's
important for us as consumers to know
yeah and then we also had to like do
housewives chat and he did top 10 one of
the best housewives impressions i've
ever seen in my life of noella jackie i
was
i couldn't breathe like i actually
couldn't i'm sure it's so good wow i
can't wait to listen to that i'm so
interested by this american airlines i'm
excited to watch your interview yeah
because i think it's going to set an
interesting precedent like whichever way
it goes because these tools like the
point sky app which is like so fabulous
and you should have all of your
information in one place like they
shouldn't be allowed to take that away
no totally and he's just out here
fighting for the consumer and so i just
wanted him to have a platform he's been
doing a lot of press but i want him to
like sit down and explain because it's
like kind of confusing um and i just
think we should be informed consumers
and he's just like so funny and great on
the podcast so i figured while i'm in
studio i might as well
move things around and jackie we moved
our couches so i could sit in front of
our neon sign underneath our couch our
carpet is bright white i guess i didn't
realize how disgusting this carpet was
until we moved the couches wow i mean
it's gross
i think we did know we just didn't want
to know i'm glad there's a there's a
piece of it though that is still
intact and
i just don't know who these airlines
think they are these days because it's
like you guys need to figure your [ __ ]
out and the last thing you should be
worried about is brian kelly making our
lives easier totally you should really
you should be interested in making our
lives easier as well and not starting
stuff with the consumers so we could be
loyal to you right because you make it
really hard these days so it was a very
eye-opening interview it was really fun
it's at the end of the episode if you're
on youtube we've recorded it in studio
so it'll be a separate video so it's
just like fun to like sit down and chat
and now that i've we literally
rearranged furniture so i can do this
show from here whenever i want and i
think it looks premium
it looks so premium i am working out my
premiumness you guys you're not going to
believe this but my costco order was
cancelled i can't with you i really
can't but i have i found another vendor
i don't want to jinx it so it should be
here by our next show which is monday
because you are hitting the road
tomorrow for the end log tour so
thursday and friday there is no regular
morning toast but there will be patreon
podcast episodes up we recorded one
yesterday dear toasters for the patreon
and you guys you really
you've got you don't want to miss out
you've got some questions in quandaries
and we're here to help we did it i don't
want to miss it we really did our best
sometimes i just feel so unqualified to
be giving people advice especially when
they write in and they're like actually
going through real like life changes and
problems i'm like who the hell am i no i
feel qualified to give the advice but
it's just it's so hard to get the full
picture from you know just a paragraph
so we're working with limited
information and we're doing the best
that we can but uh i think that i think
we give really good advice i think we
give very like
hamish
was you know not
nothing radical just like good we're not
radical girlies no just some good sound
advice yeah i agree yeah
so you'll check that out tomorrow on
patreon.com morning toast but in the
meantime while we still have you we have
a great show so jam-packed yes
vanderpump rules recap fast five of
course interview with brian kelly um i
actually really enjoyed the vanderpump
rolls reunion last night
same even though i had a lot of problems
with some of the logistics like not
really understanding why people were uh
recording from home and then
once they were home they weren't even in
the first 30 minutes of the episode why
why because i think it would have been
annoying to have them like chiming in
from home they didn't want it to be a
remote
reunion again um and i think what from
what i understood like they were sick
and i think they probably didn't know
what it was or covetous pending or maybe
they just had covid or were exposed in
like a very real way and it just you
know that goes against covid protocol so
they had to do it from home but yeah no
not having lala like just on site
definitely was a loss for me i couldn't
agree more such a loss but the worst the
season the better the reunion the air go
it's been a nice reunion so far i agree
i'm excited to talk about it in the tv
recap and just generally just like chill
with you jax like love to chill are you
okay
i love to chill what's wrong
i'm just so excited chill who hurt you
chill are you gonna be okay no i'm
running on overdrive this has been the
busiest week ever last yesterday was the
longest day of my life and i capped it
off with my barnes and noble book club
which was so fun like just love talking
about myself taylor's trekker taylor
strecker one year later finally read my
book and she literally finished it like
a minute before the barnes and noble
thing started and so she had so many
questions i actually had forgotten like
she played an integral role i didn't
name her in the book but she was of the
person in my book who told me at my
first shows back at caroline's that like
people were planning to protest me doing
comedy and she was like i can't believe
that was me and she had such a pitch she
was like should i have not told you that
i'm like no no i didn't this book was
not meant to like bring up you know
skeletons it's all good
oh my god that's so i didn't realize
that was her that yeah like such a long
time ago i know and i'm so glad and
jealous of her that she had the
experience of reading the book for the
first time most recently she said she's
so funny she's such a grandma she was
like i
listen to the book on tape is that okay
i'm like the book on tape oh the audible
oh yeah the audiobook um and i'm like
yeah girl that's fine i worked super
hard on the audiobook check it out a lot
of the redheads in the redheads facebook
group ask the question constantly does
it count if that you write a book if
it's an audiobook one thousand percent
yes 100
100 percent don't don't let them forget
like you guys you need to give yourself
some credit you got to the moral of a
story you read the book
a hundred it totally counts like in my
mind and anyone who says otherwise is
just like a snob yeah for real next will
be saying reading on kindle doesn't
count
oh please nuts i actually finished my
book last night maybe you should talk to
someone by laurie gottlieb and it was no
good morning monster and
um
did you see that
lauren bostick and dear media are
turning good morning monster into like a
scripted podcast yes i did it's gonna
that's gonna be so good with option for
tv which is gonna be so good you know
what's so cool about lauren and michael
like they told us they were like trying
to do that and they actually did it yeah
no they people say stuff all the time
they get stuff done
yeah
um
so yes it was a busy day and we're going
into an even busier weekend with my
shows i'm really excited so that's why i
was just acting all weird i'm like i
might be short-circuiting okay let us
know keep us posted on your circuits and
we're here for you and this is a safe
space where you can act as erratic as
you want really yeah i just want to just
make sure to check in with you that like
you are okay
currently yes i saw you drinking a soda
and it's like a little maybe that's the
reason
well we have that's possible but we
haven't been in the studio in literally
two months because of kovid so there
aren't many drinks it was either this or
a spritz and so i thought this was more
responsible use code toast at
supportsociety.com oh my god just
imagine if you start drinking
i guess that's when you'll know like if
you ever that's the line like if you're
ever drinking on this show
but i don't know as we keep doing it
later and later the line starts to blur
agreed
oh also for um i keep forgetting to
mention this and ben is going to kill me
for anyone coming to my show at parks i
wanna let you know we will be selling
spritz and there's gonna be like so many
spritz activations so get there early
it's gonna be really fun ben has been
working on a lot of stuff and it's my
first show that's gonna be selling
spritz so i'm really excited that's
gonna be such a premium experience for
the consumer also if you've not yet
tried spritz you're feeling trepidatious
like what a great way to try it
and also what a great buzz to have while
you enjoy the n log tour
while you enjoy the end log tour
immensely immensely
do you leave for this end log tomorrow
morning
okay cool well we'll bid you a do bon
voyage and i think without further ado
well you know what's so funny bid you
would do
do you know that um i somehow ended up
on wordle talk
where people just like discuss tips and
tricks for doing wordless okay and
something really smart that people do is
they do you have like a go-to word that
you always guess first i have like one
or two yeah
so i guess like statistically a really
helpful word to use is ado
because it uses four to five vowels
so you know immediately which vowels are
in it and which are not that's a really
good tip and trick what is your go-to
word
it's either great
or price i don't know why mine is ghost
and then because it has some quirky
letters in it and st are very popular
and if there's nothing in there that's
part of it then i use the word break
a k-e or e-a-k e-a-k but it would be the
same thing because it doesn't have any
of the same letters as ghosts
got it oh that's so maybe a jew would be
accomplishing more to be honest like i
just really like the chaotic way that i
start so i i'm not going to adapt this
adieu
technology but some people are saying
it's like statistically a helpful way to
start i'm sure it is but now it also
feels a little like cheating like
knowing that a grade so i agree i'm just
going back to my ghost spooky vibe
will she get the wordle of the day oh
never know
you didn't get yesterday's wordle no
that was the first time i didn't get it
i got it on the third try
no wait sorry yesterday sugar yeah i got
it on the third try the day before
yesterday uh grassy knoll got it i got
grassy nolan on the fourth try i think
no you said fifth it's fine on the fifth
try okay i send it to you because i was
so proud so i have nothing to hide i'm
not hiding
i never said you were okay
now without further ado even though it's
the ado that's spelled differently than
the word allah do i believe
i believe as well it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and i got my cards back y'all if you're
watching on youtube so premium i got my
cards back for today's ads because
today's ad i wanted to feel peaceful
knowing that i'm gonna be talking about
calm and i needed my handy-dandy cards
so it's the new year which means we've
all got exercise on the brain but really
what you need is to exercise your brain
resolve to strengthen your mind with a
mindful practice and just like a new gym
routine you may need a little help from
a trainer that's where calm comes in
we're partnering with com the number one
mental wellness app to give you the
tools that improve the way you feel
clear your head with guided daily
meditations improve your focus with
com's curated music tracks and drift off
to dreamland with com's imaginative
sleep stories for children and adults if
you go to com.com toast you get a
limited time offer for 40 off com
premium subscription which includes
hundreds of hours of programming and new
content is added every week
so you can use com for a multitude of
things i obviously use it for sleep and
one of my favorite stories to listen to
is it's like i don't know who it is but
it sounds like this really old wise man
talking about the lavender fields in
provence and it's just so gorgeous and i
fall asleep to it quite frequently
because i have a lot of trouble sleeping
and that's what i use it for but you can
use it for meditation you could really
use it for a lot of things um and they
do a lot of cool partnerships throughout
the year with like different celebrities
it's just a great platform and it's
great to just it's worth the
subscription
you can sleep more stress less and live
better with calm and for listeners of
our show com is offering a limited time
promotion for 40 off a premium
subscription at
com.com
toast that's
c-a-l-m-com
toast for 40 off unlimited access to
comms entire library that's com.com
toast.com.com
you know what you know in ted lasso when
they say a word so much he's like it's
starting just to sound like a sound yeah
you in garage i know
that's also calm
yeah but i like com.com toast it's great
branding com.com yeah also might i
suggest after this episode you do a comm
meditation and
name
today's episode is also brought to you
by single drunk female samantha fink is
a person in progress and being a person
is hard single drunk female is the new
free-form original series now streaming
on hulu from the executive producer of
girls and the executive producer of
russian doll samantha used to get drunk
all the time but now she's getting clean
and it's gonna get real messy fresh out
of rehab samantha is forced to move back
home and live with her mom who she
affectionately calls her smother
she's working at a local grocery store
taking naps in the cereal aisle and
going to meetings sam's sobriety is one
day at a time but the days just keep on
coming with her former drinking buddy
and newly found friends of the program
by her side sam is trying to make the
most of her second chance a chance to
start over and a chance to be a slightly
better person a chance at love when you
start at rock bottom the only way to go
is up check out the new dramedy that is
sure to make you laugh even if sometimes
it's just to keep you from crying
freeform's single drunk female you can
now stream on hulu
great okay let's get into the stories
lots to chat about today first up
jenny wen has been fired from the real
housewives of salt lake city amid
backlash from controversial social media
posts
so bravo posted a statement yesterday
saying bravo has ceased filming with
jenny nguyen and she will no longer be a
cast member on the real housewives of
salt lake city we recognize we fail to
take appropriate action once her
offensive social media posts were
brought to our attention moving forward
we will work to improve our processes to
ensure we make better informed and more
thoughtful casting decisions
then jenny posted last night to her
instagram and twitter that she's going
to be speaking out today speaking her
truth and answering questions that has
not happened yet but tbd on what she
will say and just content warning at the
end of the episode me and brian do talk
about this again so i i want to hear
your take but we did discuss it yes so
we saw this this week and we also i had
seen that she was filming with the lady
so i figured that this was going to be
addressed on this next season they had
just filmed the reunion otherwise it
would have come up at the reunion and
i i don't know why i was really
surprised that bravo dropped the axe
here on her i feel like it's been a
while since we've had one of these like
cancellation situations and in all that
time like everyone you know would say
they're against cancer culture but like
this seems like textbook cancel culture
to me and i just don't know how
productive it is to just like fire her
goodbye as opposed to like if she did
film with the women they all have a lot
to say about this that's true and they
could have conversations and actually
like leave room for like growth
understanding healing but like stuff
like this just like cements a divide and
a misunderstanding between people and
leaves like no opportunity for learning
so i just i don't i don't
think it i don't think it's that
productive to do it this way and if they
really wanted i think it could be so
much more powerful to just to talk about
these things instead especially since
the women have really strong opinions
about it
no i agree in theory but like i just
[ __ ] hate jenny so like you know what
goodbye like she added nothing of value
to the show and honestly i don't think
she does a really good job of getting
her point across when it's about you
know dumb housewives drama i don't know
how good of a job she could have done
talking about the political climate and
racial issues no i i agree with that and
also you know she's not hasn't been my
favorite housewife either so it's not
like this huge loss and i think a lot of
people feel that way they're like okay
bye jenny like we didn't care that much
to begin with but it just also made me
think about like the way that bravo
handles these things in general and all
the different paths that they've taken
and what i think in hindsight has been
like the best course of action because
like this reminds me of a lot of
different things that have happened
first of all like leanne being fired
from real housewives of dallas but see
leanne's situation reminds me most of
the marriage
because they both said egregious things
on camera which in my opinion not that
anything is worse or better because what
jenny posted like about killing
protesters like that's horrible
but doesn't it seem like it would be a
worse offense if we're just like if
we're categorizing these things which i
guess we are doesn't it seem like a
worse offense to say something
derogatory and racist
on the show yeah no and that's why i was
actually really supportive even though
i'm super against cancel culture like i
actually thought leanne going like was
the right move yeah at the time but then
it's like okay so let's also talk about
what happened with mary this season and
how she offended jenny and everyone the
mexican community right oh right and
everyone would have expected that she
would be fired after the reunion for
those comments because it's really like
the same thing as what happened
to leanne but that we never got there
because she didn't show up to the
reunion
then we also have like kristin and
stassi on vanderpump rules who were
fired but then i think and then we also
have like brandy
on real house eyes of dallas yes
the season where you know she's really
grappling with the mistake that she made
and she has a lot of conversations with
tiffany moon about the uh hurt that she
caused and i felt like that was
productive you know that's actually a
really good point and even though this
past season of real housewives of new
york city was so painful to watch i i
felt like there were moments when they
were having real conversations about
things even though
at the time
it was just like no one wanted to say it
was like messy and and there were so
many other like not
enjoyable things about the season but i
felt like they were really like moving
the the ball in terms of like
understanding each other
and and growing and learning from stuff
as opposed to just like shutting people
down when they
say the wrong thing
yeah i mean i guess we have to hear what
where jenny stands like it's very
possible she said she's going to tell
her truth like is she going to come on
and stand by what she said even though
she did already release a statement she
and she apologized yeah
i don't know see me and brian were
talking about this too i think there's
i don't know what the right way to
handle it was but there are definitely
two
schools of thought here people are like
get rid of her or people are like why
don't we hold her accountable on the
season and have her you know sit face to
face with you know
all the women including women of color
and justify like that's punishment it is
like that's no but that's being held
accountable you know having to answer
for what you've done and to like have
conversations about it as opposed to
like just being fired i don't i feel
like being the word accountable has just
become a euphemism for being canceled
yeah no i i hear you i don't know what
the right decision is but personally
i'm down with the firing because she
sucks
like yes i'm not going to miss her as a
housewife so you know i'm going to miss
carlin i know i know that this whole
thing was really tough on you for carlin
but also like i i take umbrage with
bravo for a number of reasons here like
so first of all back to the leanne thing
i feel like they waited to see like how
the audience was gonna feel about it
before they made a decision and then
this season like really the exact same
thing happened with mary cosby and if
bravo had any scruples they would have
fired her the next day after those
comments were made because like that's
the precedent so it just feels like they
sort of wait around to see what
everybody like wants them to do and it
doesn't come from a place of like they
feel this way or they have strong
principles it's just like oh it's
performative it's actually the
definition of performative and there's
been a lot of critical feedback for
bravo especially as it pertained to this
issue like if you read their comments on
the statement on instagram people are
calling them out like
hard i agree with you like they there's
no
they don't have like a template that
they follow they just like see what the
reaction is
yeah it's they're spineless yeah they
don't they have no scruples i completely
agree also like they go through
extensive background checks these women
that's how noella even found out that
her husband wasn't dead it like blew up
her entire life like
so i i mean i can't imagine that they
saw like they saw these posts and and
they hired her or or but how do they you
not like to do it it's messy doing like
someone's social media
uh
history is like the
text first background check these days
so i just
i don't understand
i agree no it's been handled very poorly
by bravo and it's
it's eliciting different reactions from
people but i think overall the message
is like okay but what about mary and
also a lot of the comments are okay
ramona me and brian were talking about
that at the end of the episode because
like
you can't bring that's the thing it's
like there's no equal
there's no equality like not equality
but you know what i mean like they're
not handling each situation the same
yeah but also i feel like ramona messes
up a lot on the show and says the wrong
thing quite often is often like very
ignorant and offensive and doesn't
realize and she has moments of learning
throughout the show and like i i do feel
like from if years ago like she is a
more
understanding sympathetic
person i don't know if everyone would
agree with you on that but i hear you
you know i so i feel like there's like
opportunities for the viewers and for
the ladies themselves to like learn from
these situations and i just i don't know
that just like
firing her just like that
was the
ultimately does anything productive or
leads toward healing in general we're so
divided like let's let's bring people
together and have some hard
conversations
yeah i think maybe they would have taken
that route if jenny was a housewife
worth saving and that's really at the
end of the day that's what it comes down
to i'm sorry okay i was not a housewife
worth saving she gave she gave nothing i
think that's a fair assessment and that
could also explain why ramona sticks
around you know what because say what
you want about ramona she's deeply
problematic
she is entertaining she provides value
to a franchise year after year say what
you want about her but we're always
talking about her i have not had one
thing to say about jenny this season
except cringe
yeah and carlin
sure yeah but carlin's got her sign on
saturdays and
she'll be okay she's gonna be fine yeah
but dewey might be you know
looking for a new sister right and then
also it's like so she said last week on
the show that she broke her husband's
ribs in a fit of anger
oh my god i totally forgot about that
like that what that was giving bronwyn
like
what
why
why are we letting an actual abuser on
the show it was so weird so again just
like their scruples are all over the
place
agreed oh my god i totally forgot about
that she's just so problematic she has
to go okay well she's gone and now
they're down to five women who knows if
they'll bring someone else on but then
also yesterday heather and
shaw were spotted like outside mary's
church filming like looking for mary
yeah also meredith like responded to a
tweet because someone was like you
shouldn't even be on the show like you
don't even like these women and you're
always walking away and she was like no
like you're right so like is she leaving
also
yeah
i don't know she is above it in my
opinion she is there maybe maybe they'll
bring in some new p i mean i think they
have to bring in new people now so we'll
see yeah what happens but
but it's not going to be jenny no but
it's also interesting that they're
filming while the season is still airing
it feels like a very quick turnaround
does it not there's just a lot happening
it does but i also feel like bravo is
needing to like make up for lost coveted
time um yeah yeah you know plus with
everything like changing by the day with
gen shaw they don't want to miss
anything
right right
right because we've totally gotten off
track like of that storyline oh yeah
goodbye goodbye
are you ready for our next story
i am i really really am kanye west is
sitting down with jason lee of hollywood
unlocked and sharing that he stopped a
second sex tape of kim and ray j from
leaking
the yeezy designer told jason lee that
despite his ongoing divorce from kim he
allegedly did her the ultimate favor and
got the tape back he said i went and got
the laptop from ray j myself that night
i met this man at the airport then got
on a red eye came back and delivered it
to her at 8 a.m in the morning he said
that kim was so relieved at the sight of
the laptop that she broke down in tears
he said she cried when she saw it you
know why she cried when she seen it on
the laptop because it represents how
much she's been used it represents how
much people didn't love her and they
just saw her as a commodity a
spokesperson for kim confirmed there was
a laptop but denied the existence of any
explicit content they said the computer
and hard drive collected were supposed
to contain the original video and any
unseen footage after review there was
nothing sexual unseen only footage on
the plane on the way to mexico and
footage at a club and restaurant on the
same trip kim remains firm in her belief
that there is no new second sex tape
that exists after 20 years she truly
wishes to move on from this chapter
literally and focus instead on the
positive things she continues to do as a
mother entrepreneur and advocate for
justice reform amen i've really had
enough no this story gives me a pit
and you know what it feels very icky to
me that kanye is out doing a podcast
and maybe this wasn't his intention or
whatever but he's out doing a podcast
just like talking about his ex-wife the
mother of his children's sex tape like
seriously
this is like the first time
where like i i actually cannot defend
kanye like i i'm actually upset i'm
upset too
i do feel like when he goes on these
podcasts especially like long form he's
just talking and he's not like thinking
about like you know the what this means
and the fact that like after everything
that kim has been through like to bring
it back to the sex tape also for you to
go out of your way to like rescue her
quote unquote and get the tape back only
to tell everyone about it what's the
point
so i this story just like really um
bothers me me too
and
it just kim has come so far and i'm sure
it really bothers her too and you can
tell from this statement they're like
they're like fighting back but you know
what like kim and i think she's
maintained this and i think she'll
continue to maintain this
philosophy as for as long as she can
like she will not say a bad word
publicly about kanye but he's making it
extremely difficult yeah
yeah he's being like super
like a dick i know just at public these
days like he should right the kids the
security guards they won't let me into
kylie's party like doing the podcasts
like
come on the toast kanye you have
something you want to say uh-oh could we
handle it
of course yeah
yeah we could we could um
i
doesn't bode well there's a lot like
he's just every day it's something new
with him him and julie
and it's just not a recipe
i'm over it over it and i'm
it's feeling inauthentic
to say it's giving it's giving
inauthenticity yeah it is
so
that's that on that are you ready for
our next story
if it's the next story that's brought to
you by turbo tax
people think unusual circumstances mean
complicated taxes but for turbotax live
experts that's what makes things
interesting maybe you inherited a condo
and are renting it out or maybe you're
paid in crypto and aren't sure how it's
taxed for turbotax live experts an
interesting life can mean an even
greater refund and luckily turbo
turbotax live can match you with the
right experts who have experience in
your unique situation and can answer all
of your tax questions right from your
phone or computer they can even take
care of the whole filing process for you
whether you launched your own startup or
are working multiple jobs juggling
multiple incomes an experienced turbo
tax live expert can help you during the
entire filing process or do your taxes
for you from start to finish to get you
the tax deduction you deserve visit
turbotax.com to learn more you do your
thing they've got your taxes and two at
turbo tax live great
cardi b is speaking out after being
awarded an additional three million
dollars in a slander lawsuit against a
youtuber
so cardi b was awarded nearly three
million three million dollars in
punitive damages and attorneys fees in
her lawsuit against youtuber tasha cabe
aka tasha k
jurors ruled on tuesday that cabe is
responsible for one million dollars in
punitive damages her company was ordered
to pay an additional five hundred
thousand dollars and she will have to
reimburse cardi b for the rapper's legal
costs which add up to 1.3 million
dollars
cardi b said in a statement shared with
people after almost four years of
repeated libel and slander against me
being able to walk away from this
victorious brings me great happiness i
appreciate judge rae for conducting a
fair and impartial trial i'm grateful
for the jury and their careful
deliberation over the past two weeks i
am profoundly grateful for the hard work
and support from my legal team most
importantly thank you to my family and
close friends who held my hand and
helped me get the support i needed
during this experience
you know this is really crazy because
i actually love when celebrities win
defamation suits because we just live in
like a
a society and we have a legal system
that really doesn't protect public
figures from people just saying whatever
the [ __ ] they want about them
um
but i don't know i feel a little
conflicted that like this is
about a youtuber do you know what i mean
it's not like it's not like cardi's
suing you know buzzfeed that has like
millie like i i have to assume this
youtuber does not have three million
dollars
uh it doesn't say but it the remarks um
in the lawsuit filed accused her of
making malicious claims against her such
as alleging the rapper was a prostitute
cheated on her husband used cocaine and
contracted herpes and hpv
she also um said that when cardi b was
pregnant with her daughter culture it
could result in a child born with
special needs
oh okay sorry i totally take back what i
said and though i don't know this
youtuber um
i'm sure it's like a gossip channel and
i'm sure that she has enough
circulation the fact that this even like
reached cars on her radar and like
really weighed heavily on her i think it
was a source of a lot of like
sadness and depression for her and she
talks about you know like the mental
health consequences of being on the
internet in general for like you know
kids in school and she has the means and
the resources to fight back against
online bullies and that's what she's
gonna do
so i i think this is a good precedent to
set yeah no it's true and it does
definitely make you think about like
social media
personalities as news sources and like
where the accountability lies like
honestly my first thought when i saw
this was like dumois
yeah
yeah it's like this gray area where
you're not a news outlet but you have an
enormous platform and sometimes like
you're just saying blanket things and
and does that include you like could you
technically be
liable in a defamation lawsuit and i
think the sense sets like an interesting
legal precedent yeah i don't know how
how it works like all the time but uh
it's definitely an interesting
crossroads you know it's just like a
first time thing it also reminds me of
like heather mcdonald
and the gym what was his name jimbo
yeah like she and shannon and she
actually ended up winning her lawsuit
which was like a huge thing for
podcasters but it's just like this gray
area that we're now in we're like
podcasting like this kind of grassroots
type of media
has just as much influence and as much
of a platform as like major news outlets
so like are you suppo like are we being
held to the same standard it's just like
an interesting conversation
yeah it is and i think that you know i
these cases are very hard to win so for
the celebrities so you know there was
clearly
defamatory disgusting thing to say like
no wonder like
it obviously got bothered cardi like
those are horrible things to say yeah
yeah
so
a little bit of justice
wait
got my gavel
just yes
has been served nice
are you ready for our next story yes
disney is rethinking snow white after
peter dinklage calls out the use of
dwarves it's time it's time yep so peter
dinklage was on a podcast mark maron's
wtf podcast and love to see podcast
making news he slammed the new snow
white and the seven dwarves film which
has been um talked about rachel zegler
is playing
snow white oh is she yes and he called
the use of dwarves [ __ ] backwards
uh he
was saying literally no offense to
anyone but i was a little taken aback
when they were very proud to cast a
latina actress as snow white but you're
still telling the story of snow white
and the seven dwarves take a step back
and look at what you're doing there it
makes no sense to me you're progressive
in one way but then you're still making
that [ __ ] backwards story about seven
dwarfs living in a cave together what
the [ __ ] are you doing man have i done
nothing to advance the cause for my
soapbox i guess i'm not loud enough
he said if you tell the story of snow
white with the most [ __ ] up cool or
progressive spin on it let's do it all
in
then
this caused disney to respond to what he
said they said to avoid reinforcing
stereotypes from the original animated
film we are taking a different approach
with these seven characters and have
been consulting with members of the
dwarfism community we look forward to
sharing more as the film heads into
production after a lengthy development
period
honestly they just really shouldn't like
be called dwarves because
the story should just if they change it
to like the seven
campers you know what i mean like
something else they shouldn't because
dwarves
exist in the real world so putting them
like in a fantasy is just trivializing
it like the i actually have thought for
a while how weird it was that like they
were called the seven dwarves like they
just have to change it like it's not
it's really not a big deal the story
line doesn't have to change whatsoever
but he's saying the storyline does like
there if they are like living in this
cave together like it's just you know a
misrepresentation of this community and
i really think that what he says like
sums up exactly like the the
how you could look at the script and say
we're going to be like you know
progressively aggressive and then you
glaringly miss the most offensive part
of it i agree and probably the most
offensive part of
any of the major disney
stories and i think that the movie title
like the movie it is snow white and the
seven dwarves and i don't even know if
they were going to use that title like
for this new one like it's right there
in front of your face yeah and they
think that they're like being inclusive
and progressive in other ways when
they're just missing like what's
actually because
it's comical yeah so go for it and he's
making change change is happening good
peter dinklage is a hundred percent
right and you know what
he
is an icon he's right like has he done
nothing he's so famous
and we're still not getting it
he's right he's totally right yeah so
we'll see the changes that they make
and
what the new movie will look like
i didn't know rachel zegler was playing
snow white yeah and this is the one
where gal gadot is playing
evil queen
paul are doing the soundtrack
andrew burnapp is in it oh so we need to
make it as good as possible because it's
going to be good yeah yeah but it's just
like so crazy they had all these things
checked off you know we're ready and
we're going to make this great movie
that everyone's going to love and yeah
they missed
the mark the mark completely
with mark maron
yes
okay now are you ready for our fifth and
final story
i am and i have a big surprise for
everyone okay okay
it's the final story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't be jealous you vicious wenches
yeah
and that's magic number
that was beautiful what instrument is
that claudia i'm not sure it was a gift
from artem our production coordinator
and it's from treeworks handmade in
nashville
i don't know it's like a table top
triangle
it's beautiful i feel like the principal
at the at greece you know like
yes
good morning rydell high yes
love that that is some smooth sounds um
they really should put that in their app
such as sweet and thoughtful gift i'm
getting mine today i'm really excited i
know i'll lull bruce to sleep with it
hey bruce come to heating
rice on ice
bryce on the ice
amazing our fifth and final story
switching gears completely
completely which you know i love to do
starting in 2024 u.s students will take
the sat entirely online
i guess that's
accurate i can feel that the sat a
college admissions exam long associated
with paper and pencil pencils down will
soon go all digital starting in 2023 for
international students and 24 for the
u.s the new digital sat will shrink from
three hours to two include shorter
reading passages and allows someone nice
and allow students to use a calculator
on the math sections you're kidding yeah
i mean at this point in technology you
can't say you're not always going to
have a calculator with you though i
would imagine that this will mean that
the math section will be harder
yeah that's true but you know what like
i actually feel really jealous like the
shorter time doing it from home those
were some of the worst sundays of my
life like getting up so early
hours and hours of tests and like little
snacks you had to eat between like i
[ __ ] hated taking the sats tests will
still take place at school though but
students will be able to choose between
using their own devices including a
tablet tablet or a laptop if they can
get one
from home it's just digital it's just
digital or the school's devices okay but
i'm i feel like what's to stop
eventually from being from home there
are all these new technology platforms
now that like
where people like in college were taking
exams and like the computer is like
watching you and you can't open other
tabs and you can't like i don't know
screw and cheat even though like
what's to stop you from having something
like right next to your having a
textbook literally next to your computer
i don't know
maybe just the honor code
that's really curious i wouldn't trust
the honor code with these kids
yeah how do you need a 360 camera
yeah but i guess if you're on the
computer in school there's still a
proctor yes of course of course i'm not
worried about it for that but when
people were doing exams from home
even though they they use these like
apps that make sure that they're
watching you
i have something right here next they
were definitely cheating like there's no
way around it yeah it's okay if you took
exams in college in like the pandemic
what were you cheating and how and if
you weren't were others were there ways
to get or what
uh even your phone like you keep your
phone looking you can't see my phone
right here or what systems do they have
in place to make sure that you couldn't
do that stuff
something to think about anyways i mean
this seems like you know
pretty obvious
but it's also kind of shocking because i
feel like the sat could have been one of
those things it's just like it's a test
and it's always going to be it's not
like we've done away with pencil and
paper in general yeah so
especially if they're still going into
the school
yeah and
i do feel like in some situations it's
it might be more helpful to be on a
computer but like for a reading section
reading on a computer is like not really
ideal
yeah like you have to read your whole
passage on the computer yeah but it's
nice for when you have to i don't know
if this writing section
they didn't writing of course that's
what so helpful clickety clack you could
write your whole essay in literally
seven minutes yeah
that's probably what also was taking
less time
yes for the campers
yes the manual labor of pen and paper
yeah and maybe this will mean you'll get
your scores back sooner
who knows
so that's just a big shift i think yeah
me too no it's like we're gonna be able
to tell our kids like oh yeah i took
that test but back in my day we had to
write it yeah we had to fill in the
bubble
crazy mm-hmm
um so we're officially old i guess
that's what it means yes yes it does
last
day i wasn't sure but now i am
okay tv recap let's do it all right tv
recap vanderpump rules reunion part one
of only two which i felt like we didn't
we didn't cover a lot of ground so i was
like surprised that there's only two uh
episodes and the second part is tonight
it is yeah it's not next week which is
like kind of a stunning beautiful thing
oh they're just like ending yeah they're
just like goodbye good day sir but
because they're doing it in this way i'm
like very much into it maybe they really
maybe they want to start filming like
fast
maybe
well the reunion recap is brought to you
by home addicts here's why you got to
check them out they have a whole line of
massage products from a massage gun with
a built-in hot and cold technology to a
massage cushion that lets you lie down
or sit up depending on your therapeutic
needs to a three and one foot massager
with vibration so powerful it loosens
the muscles in your legs and lower back
so they have a ton of products but
whatever you're struggling with whether
it's a sore back a sore neck i know
pregnancy-wise jackie you've been using
their products a lot um their massagers
address the pain points from head to toe
i have tried their um
massage cushion which is something a
unique experience that i've never
experienced ever before just like laying
down on my couch and getting a full body
rub down it's insane it's so worth it
it's just great to have like products
that really target i have lower back
issues because of my enormous breasts um
they have an a plus better business
bureau rating so they're a brand you can
rely on
they send us a lot of their products i
literally use that back cushion every
day and if you if you work out um
it's a great thing to use right after it
helps you with your recovery so you're
not so sore whether you're dealing with
chronic pain or just looking to help
your muscles recover from a workout
we've got good news right now if you go
to homedics.com toast and use the promo
code toast you'll receive a free
portable phone sanitizer when you buy a
hundred dollars or more in massage
products it's a sixty dollar value at
hometics h o m e d i c s dot com slash
toast and use the promo code toast for
your free portable phone sanitizer
within a hundred dollar purchase of a
massager check it out
great
so vanderbilt girls okay so i texted you
last night because i was like shook at
the reunion james was being so iconic
last night like he was just being so
funny like when he literally walked out
when they were talking about charlie's
food party like i couldn't agree more
i'm sorry for what you're going through
but like we really don't care um he was
being so funny when rocket was like um
do you want the ring back right now he's
like
sure sure that's a bitcoin that's a
bitcoin he was just being really funny
and he was also being very genuine and
earnest and and i know it was i guess i
didn't realize that like raquel really
broke up with him yeah
and that was my biggest takeaway from
the evening yeah no he was being really
honest on all counts and i appreciated
it i agree when he stormed off because
he didn't want to talk about curry and
samosas
i was just like you know none of us
wanted to watch it or either and even
when andy like asked charlie the
question he was like viewers you've got
a lot of positivity about how open you
were about your food struggles like can
you tell us more about that because
still like
i don't know what they are
well also
why was charlie like a full-time cast
member like
aside from that food thing she was not
involved whatsoever well they just need
like warm bodies people yeah i think
that if everybody else had shown up to
the reunion she would have had like a i
guess if brock can be there then she can
be there i'm sorry brock was the whole
season brock is
an animal
favorite person oh i just can't [ __ ]
stand and now him coming for james and
james is like slowly becoming one of my
favorite people same i'm just like no no
no
no no
um it was really sad to hear from james
and raquel but i agree with tom
schwartz like it takes a lot of courage
to make that choice right now and not to
like let years go by or you know you
don't want to disrupt what's comfortable
or just uproot your life and i have so
much respect for the two of them
especially because you would think
they're two people who like
they're living this la life they're on
the show seemingly fine it's not
terrible easy for them to stay together
so many people are invested in their
relationship and instead they're taking
the harder path and i have a lot of
respect for that also because like not
even just in the public eye of dealing
with a breakup but like going through a
breakup you know a lot of people just
like keep stay or keep going back
because it's like i don't want to be
alone did you get the vibe that like
raquel might be leaving the show yeah
because she was saying like she wants to
work and she doesn't want like the la
life is not really
good for her what's best for her i have
so much respect for raquel the
flashbacks the way that she's grown over
the years she's like it's a really
wonderful thing to witness it's not
something you get to see from people
that often because you know
no not a lot of people have like all
this years of footage of their life but
like she really has grown into a
wonderful
self-assured but still so sweet woman
and
that was lovely to see because i think
sometimes reality tv has the opposite
effect i agree it was like a beautiful
moment
yeah um and i i definitely felt like she
might not be returning yeah especially
now that jane they're not together it's
james is obviously staying on the show
that's even harder on a breakup when
like you're trying to move away from
someone and you they're in your everyday
life i think that it would be best for
her i'll miss her shockingly
but i think she should go and she should
do the things that she wanted to do with
her life and this was will have just
been like a fun
interim thing that she also just get the
vibe like she comes from family money
and like she doesn't need the show oh i
mean i i get the vibe that her family is
not at all impressed or interested in
her being on the show i don't think
she's like can not work necessarily no
but i don't think she needs the show
like some of the others kind of need
financially yeah and i think some of the
others like might be a little bit
more untethered
from their families whereas like she can
always just like go back home get her
degree in what she wanted to do and get
to work whereas like some i don't want
to like
some other people like where would they
even start if they left the show
speaking of financials the whole
conversation about
the loans and
i forgot that lisa had offered to buy
them out plus a hundred thousand dollars
like
i wanted to die and then also seeing
their progress which is nothing
knowing that they're sinking their
mortgages their
savings i know sandoval said he like
takes care of his family i'm heartbroken
about schwartz sorry i am heartbroken
over schwartz and sandy's i think in
retrospect they will think it is the
dumbest thing they ever did
i
i think sandoval is responsible
for
forcing schwartz into this arrangement
making them like this stupid duo who
need to open another restaurant and i
think it is an enormous mistake
i agree
the progress or lack thereof was
a joke it was a joke a joke and it was
interesting to hear katie say
and this has never been the narrative
that sandoval is like not a good easy
person to work with like doesn't show up
doesn't answer stuff like i think when
he's in front of a diva when he's in
front of you he's giving you the most
most most but then wherever he is
wherever he is when you're not with him
he's giving all that to the next person
and like there's he's not
balanced in his work ethic i found
because you would think like between if
based on what we saw on the show between
top sandoval and schwartz that like
sandoval does most of the work of the
work but no
no i love katie and yes she's obviously
biased because schwartz is her husband
but i do believe she's an extremely
accurate historian like i believe
her pov for of things yeah no and
schwartz is like not it's not like she's
ever said that before or anything close
to it i think she can like see schwartz
for who he is and he's like yeah like
goofy and lovable and so i i don't think
she would say that if it wasn't true
because it's so counter to like what you
would expect from the two of them agreed
i thought they all looked really great
sheena um
it's just awful like really awful
but
i didn't know about her um birth story
and i actually thought it sounded really
similar to olivia
yeah
with the preeclampsia and i actually i
had a lot of sympathy for her um
but like i don't know why she she dies
on every hill like she can't just like
really let anything go like even with
the tv thing it was funny like let it go
oh my god it was funny and it was
hysterical actually yeah she it was
really crazy to watch like her minions
turn on her i don't think she ever
expected that from charlie and that's
why i'm not like fully out on charlie
because i sometimes she just surprises
me in the most i respect it unexpected
ways yeah and she has a lot of uh
it's true like you you would have
thought last season like she was a mini
sheena but like she said i'm not sheena
and oma she had actually some great
one-liners i don't need attention i'm
not you yeah
she was being like kind of funny she was
and
it was like sheena's like the world was
like crumbling around her when even
raquel like couldn't lie for her for
danica and what did danica do danica
what did danica do to sheena that meant
cutting her out from everyone's lives i
have no idea and like sounds like
danica's really toxic sounds like we
need her on the show sounds like we need
her on the show yeah the show needs
more
toxicity no it just like needs more
people and
it's yes
i don't know where they're gonna and i
think they realize like nobody wants
actually new people
you know no they don't not unless they
come on in like brock you know sheena's
man or something like that or raquel
when andy accidentally called brock robb
oh my god
iconic i'd love to see it and you know i
i've said it once and i'll say it again
i've really been enjoying lisa
vanderpump this season i think this new
hybrid role she's taken on as like a
mentor is so the role she should have
been playing for the last couple years
instead of fake boss
agreed
um but so really not a lot happened and
that's why i was so surprised it was
giving part one of three but it's part
one of two yeah i think they're just
kind of like getting it over with maybe
because the season like didn't perform
well or something but the more that
they're being brusqued about it the more
interested i am if it were three parts i
would be complaining through every part
because that would have mean we got even
less last night like i'm excited to
watch again tonight to put the season
behind me and i hope they start filming
again but i hope they make um
a few changes a few changes have you
ever thought about like if they brought
back stassi and kristen
no honestly for me like it's over
especially kristin yeah i guess kristen
like doesn't really fit into because
lisa just like really [ __ ] hates
kristin yeah but lisa and stasi i know
we're close like i guess i could
envision a world where saucy came back
but you know what i don't think it would
work
in anyone's best interest like it's over
yeah or jackson brittany
uh beyond over maybe britney maybe but
it was weird that they even asked about
them like that was like i felt like the
com the questions were just like so
random
um but watching jax like in the
flashback like just took me back to
another time say what you want jax was
an iconic reality star he was so insane
when he was like this is my show like
what
it was sorry it was so good
i do miss that chaotic toxic energy me
too and i do feel like james has stepped
up to the plate
and it's actually a shame because i they
never could see eye to eye but i think
that because james has like matured a
little bit and he's less like like now
he when he's like pops off like he's
popping off with purpose as opposed to
top it off with purpose as opposed to in
the past when he just like would go b
maybe it's like because of the um
no longer drinking he still has his
anger issues but like they're not it's
not as like distracted and it's very
like you know he knows what he's angry
about um and i just feel like jackson
james would get along these days i agree
and i would have loved to see them
taking the town together yeah and also x
not being here has you know paved the
way for everyone to see sandoval for the
villain that he is yes and you know what
i'd love to see it
so all right i guess it's over tonight
and there's no episode tomorrow but um
we'll talk about it next week if you're
listening as a podcast don't go anywhere
we've got an interview with brian kelly
and if you're watching on youtube and
you want to watch youtube it's just the
next video on our channel
um and that's our last show of the week
you guys because i'm headed to philly in
dc i can't wait to see you guys i'm very
excited to be back on tour it's gonna be
so fun brian's coming counselor's coming
ben's coming counselor's coming
counselor's only coming to
parks but it's gonna be a full family
affair and i'm very excited that's
really exciting i hope you guys have a
great weekend well we're gonna miss you
but take care of elsie okay be a good
little camper
and we love you guys thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find out
some morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing hump day oh i didn't even
mention that i was humped that's how
busy the day was have an amazing hump
day enjoy the rest of your week we can't
wait to see you guys out on the road
this weekend i love you goodbye goodbye
and if you're looking for more content
from your girls head over to patreon.com
morning toast if you join patreon today
there is literally so much content there
waiting for you you could watch to start
it right now and
be done on monday when we cut when we
come back with the toast so patreon.com
toast love you dearly claude you want to
hit us with a little musical outer lewd
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye i still need to learn how to use
this thing but goodbye [ __ ] goodbye you
need to take lessons
[Music]